this video is sponsored by Kurt spell
and kog games card spell is a
free-to-play anime style action RPG for
PC that is available in the link below
right off the bat got to say that this
game honestly is one of the most
satisfying action combat systems I've
played in an anime MMO game attacks feel
good and weighty chaining combos with
special moves that's cool as hell and
overall battles can actually be quite
challenging not forgetting that it all
looks absolutely beautiful choose from a
variety of different classes to see your
play style and also create your own
character to suit whatever a protagonist
you want to be you can be an Opie anime
guy or let's be honest we're gonna be a
girl cuz when in life wouldn't I choose
to roleplay as a cute anime girl see you
can edit all the important features like
eye color hair Stalin currently the game
was in early access for North and Latin
America where you can play either PvE or
get your ass handed to you in PvP and
I've been impressed at how closely the
developers are listening to feedback and
quickly addressing any issues the player
base may have had with the game if you
want to try it out again click the link
in the description to give it a download
on Steam and with that said let's get on
with the video there's a concept I feel
has died as of late within our community
one that used to be a standard part of
getting into the medium and that is the
idea around classic anime animes that
defines their generation and pioneered
the landscape you see today it used to
be mandatory to at least go back and
watch a handful of them but nowadays not
only is there less obligation to get
yourself cultured by watching these
shows I also kind of feel like no matter
how great any new anime coming out is
there's nothing that really sticks tells
me that we could call a modern classic
io handedly mentioned in my best of
anime 2018 video that despite how great
I thought last year was it had zero
classics which is more my way of
describing that no matter how good any
show was it seemed like a sense of
impact and longevity that a lot of
greater years of anime had but it
certainly sparked an unintentional
debate in the comments section about
what exactly a classic even is and
whether it's too early to judge so today
I wanted to really dig in on that exact
topic what's lacking today and really
remind everyone why they were important
in the first place there's a lot of
different things I want to unpack in
this video so without further ado let's
just jump into it what makes a classic
fm I don't think I need to state that
the exact parameters of what defines a
classic is entirely subjective and
probably different for every person but
I guess I just did anyway most common
definitions of the word and a broader
sense simply played out to be something
of universally recognized quality and
established ongoing value however for
the sake of the arguments I'm making for
me it boils down to three main points
number one staying power classics are
classics because they have stood the
test of time no matter how many years
past they will still be relevant in
their own way there are many older anime
that have aged in some way mainly to do
with their art style or animation but
have preserved a sense of timelessness
with either their story or characters
that can be enjoyed in any era as a side
note that have been many shows that set
trends and pioneered legendary tropes on
the bleeding edge of war was fresh and
significant in a time they came out but
I've lost a lot of their luster through
these elements becoming oversaturated
years later the vision of escaflowne for
example pioneered a lot of things and
there was a time it was considered a
classic and I'm sure many still do now
though it's a lot harder to recommend
for newer audiences as most people who
watch it for the first time could see it
as some generic ISA KY mecha show
because of how overplayed many of its
tropes have become since and in my
opinion no matter how revolutionary a
show is this is a test it has to
overcome which brings me to point number
two impact I feel there needs to be a
level of impact and influence because
logically you must have been able to
impact in its own time in order for it
to be remembered and this goes in two
ways an impact on the anime industry
itself that influences future titles and
the landscape of anime or an impact on
anime pop culture and the general
audience of the time I don't think I
need to clarify what kind of impact
anime like Neon Genesis Evangelion or
Akira hats but I could talk about more
recent anime that had a profound impact
on anime pop culture if I shouted the
phrase and this is to go even further
beyond or just who the hell do you think
I am how many of you would immediately
know what I'm talking about
some classics I feel only has an impact
on the industry some on pop culture and
some doing both but I think it's
important because if an anime hits every
other category but isn't that popular or
white
when sure my opinion is closer to a cult
classic and finally number three quality
the term classic surely implies that
there would be a certain level of
quality or critical claim behind it you
can have something that's remained
relevant for years and is also widely
influential as you would see with a lot
of Gateway anime but unless there's a
general agreed consensus that it's up to
a certain level of high standards people
won't take it seriously I think the best
example of this is the sword art online
franchise which is still way more
relevant than arguably any other anime
that came out in the same year and
undoubtedly has had the popularity to
back it up while influencing the
landscape of modern anime but would
anyone actually call this a classic now
with these points in mind how many if
any could you apply all three criteria
to an anime today to me it's the feeling
of a modern classic that's been missing
from anime recently and I don't want you
to get the impression that that means
anime has gotten worse quite the
opposite in fact I think it's better
than has ever been and that might
actually be it never before is such a
wide variety of high-quality anime been
available to us in a constant drip feed
of seasonal contents never giving us a
moment's rest
we've been spoilt for choice and the
kind of shows when I think this spring
season is kind of weak just because it
only has two shows I'm super hype four
and five shows I think are pretty good
get out what do you mean I'm not
literally spending every free moment
trying to keep up with shows worth
watching like the last two seasons
while they're less shows pioneering new
things which is understandable
considering how all this medium is right
now I think the average quality and very
certainly the quantity of choice has
gone up but that's the thing if
everything special nothing is of order
three criteria it's staying power that
seems to be missing most of the time
current trends and hype series cover the
majority of what remains relevant and
impactful throughout the wider community
with the sheer density of new series
being fed to us every season it can
become easy to forget even great shows
we used to complain that anime used to
have filler seasons now it feels like we
have filler anime you could argue that
is far too early to determine which
recently aired anime has staying power
but I'd argue that you'd be hard-pressed
to find any show that lingers around for
longer than three months let alone years
or decades later just because not a lot
of time has passed doesn't mean you
can't have a good idea of what will
stick around there are in plenty of
sporting events that have been labeled
an instant classic as soon as the last
episode of Breaking Bad aired I knew was
gonna go down in television history and
with what infinity warned endgame have
achieved and how much is permeated into
general pop culture I have no doubt they
will become classics that have defined
this generation when a rare occurrence
though I will watch an anime that does
something special that would stay in my
mind for a very long time even in this
climate something that goes above and
beyond even compared to the best and has
that special x-factor you rarely see the
anime that I would say has come closest
to becoming a classic recently is mod
psycho 100 season 2 hell I know many of
you would probably argue it already is
and I completely get that season 2 of
mob psycho is one of the best anime
series I've seen in years that
completely blew the first season out of
the water if somehow leveled up is
orgasmic animation with some of the best
fight scenes of the last decade and
paired this with a heart and intimate
character writing that wasn't as
prevalent before while ending every
major plot thread it had sets up
resulting in an all-round package that
will certainly stick with me for years
to come it was just such a perfect storm
of greatness on every level that you
rarely get to see so what exactly is it
missing
well it's precisely because it's a
season to as much of a masterpiece as I
think it was a lot of people were
dropped off after season 1 which is to
be expected in the fast-paced seasonal
anime cycle and an over
two year gap between seasons even I had
trouble remembering everything the first
season left off that and I'm sure this
killed off a lot of the potential
wide-scale impact it could have had I
have no doubts that if it was one long
season or even if the gap was shorter it
would have permeated the community much
deeper than it did but as it stands it
wasn't even the most popular show of its
own season there was more discussion
around shield hero more fresh hype
around promise Netherlands and more
memes around Cali a summer this I think
perfectly illustrates why is so hard for
anime today to get a sense of longevity
right now anime has become too segmented
to have the same influence and the
community moves too fast to have the
same staying power it used to I'm sure
it's still possible it's just much
harder it has to be able to stand up
from the dozens of anime it competes
with every season it has to be given a
long enough run time to have a lasting
impact without big breaks if it's broken
up into seasons it has to be easily
accessible on a streaming platform that
the community will collectively access
and on top of that it has to be you know
really [ __ ] good I do however think
there's a small asterisk to this point
as I think every generation will have a
long-running shown in that defines that
era and goes down as a classic will
there being a staple of gateway anime
and this long-running nature allows it
far more time to build the popularity
and impact and staying power cuz well it
sticks around for so long so if there is
an exception to everything I've said
here it would of course be my hero
academia I do think this is the one show
that has done enough to be remembered
for a long time to come but I also
consider these types of shows to play by
a different set of rules than the mob
psychos of the anime world because part
of the reason the idea of classics has
died is because well we don't feel the
need to look back into the past even if
the past is just a year or two ago
there's so much to choose from now
what's the point of looking back and
thus the real reason I wanted to make
this video because over the past P month
I actually did set a bit of time to
watch some classic anime I had never
seen before and it just reminded me why
classics are indeed called classics
[Music]
two months ago I set off on an arduous
mission to start the anime that had been
sitting on my watch list for years
waiting until I was ready to take that
leap of faith to finally watch it legend
of the Galactic Heroes it was an
undertaking that was as intimidating as
the reputation that preceded it a
classic so highly spoken of has
literally been memed to death by many
people myself included as the one show
that's been put up on the highest
pedestal anime won't be the same once
you watched legends of the Galactic
Heroes they said and with this all in
mind what I found was exactly what I had
expected one of the greatest stories to
have been told in the history of anime a
tale so grand no other anime even comes
close to the scale depth and density of
the saga told here a production that
took almost ten years to complete
contained in a whopping 110 episodes for
a one-of-a-kind experience you can't
find anywhere else in this medium it's
not the kind of fast-paced instant
gratification anime more common today
but a full-length epic you gradually
immerse yourself into with a show like
this you can get so caught up in its
reputation that it can be easy to forget
how and why you've got its reputation in
the first place through this it reminded
me why there used to be this big notion
that you should go out and watch the
classics not just because it was a great
show there are plenty of great shows
that are coming out right now but
because it's a unique experience from
anything you can find today there's a
reason the classics have survived the
passage of time they might have
pioneered something they might have left
a deep impression on the audience of
their time but most importantly it's
because throughout the years that came
after nothing came along that was able
to replace them I can safely say since I
first watched Cowboy Bebop
there hasn't been any other show quite
like it serial experiments lain has a
depiction of technology that somehow
seems more relevant today than when it
came out in 1998 akira still looks
better than 90% of the anime coming out
now beyond genesis evangelion redefines
what it means to be zon refining it can
be easy to get through the currency of
ISA Kuip our fantasy highschool rom-coms
of today that
may didn't always look like this so if
you think this season is little slow and
you have some time to fill just pick a
classic title that's been collecting
dust on your watch list and I guarantee
it'll be a way more fulfilling
experience than watching another
disposable show that's been airing in
the last year whether or not you agree
on which anime houses classics or even
if you disagree with my opinion that we
haven't gotten any recently I think it's
important to keep the idea of classics
alive because it does feel like lately
there's been a depreciation in the value
of longevity and revisiting the past so
if there's anything I wanted to do with
this video it's reminding people that
there is a reason to look back it's
taking a break from the current climate
and having a look at a product of
another time it's having that
realization of oh this is what everyone
was talking about it's experiencing a
show that has done something to deserve
to be remembered because one of the
saddest things I think it happened to
classics is for them to be forgotten
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
again I want to thank Curt spell and kog
games for sponsoring this video if you
liked what I showed and want to give it
a go then just click on the link below
to download it also thank you very much
to be DD in your life Robert Hamilton
Walt o supreme sayin Nicholas Tatum
Michael from my patreon discord lets me
use one of his lines in this video there
Michael there's your free shout out and
everyone else on my patreon for helping
to support me for this month and making
this video possible
not many updates today by the time this
video comes out probably be in America
or Ireland just traveling around so yeah
I'll just leave it at that
I've been gig up and I'll see you all
next time